so hello everyone i hope you're not like
falling asleep because i was falling
asleep earlier so i hope you've had
enough coffee and are awake for my talk
if not i'm going to wake you up uh we're
going to talk about component driven
repo for component driven world and
you're probably all here because you
don't really know why you're here
because you kind of don't know even what
i'm going to talk about right and i'll
explain it all but basically i'm going
to show you how to do component driven
how to build components thinking
components first how you can build your
components outside of applications how
you can build
teams like have teams own features and
how you can just basically build better
front-end applications and hopefully
you'll go away learning something that's
the aim i'll show you a demo show you
how i built something and i'll put the
demo code at the end so you can actually
like you know scan the qr code and you
can see how i built everything and then
like don't look at my code because it's
not perfect but you can kind of just see
how it all works so that's that's what
we're all here for so i hope you enjoy
it and a little bit about me my name is
debbie o'brien i'm head developer
advocate at bit i will be using bit to
show you um how i built what i did
but basically bid is an open source tool
for building component-driven
development so um we'll kind of you'll
you'll see it but i won't really go into
actually what bit does
um i'm an open source contributor
speaker blogger youtuber isn't everyone
a youtuber these days because you know
we just all got stuck at home and
decided that was the cool thing to do
and i do a lot of sports so cycling
running paddle skiing and i'm a fourth
degree black belt in taekwondo those of
you who are sitting up close or those of
you who are watching on camera are
probably seeing the big black and blue
bruise on my head i'm probably thinking
that yes i was in a taekwondo
competition and it was really cool and i
just got like a couple of bashes and a
couple of years ago that would have been
completely correct and i've had loads of
bashes and bumps from taekwondo but
actually this one came from walking
through a revolving door getting onto
the train um at the airport because so
for some reason in norway they build
revolving doors that are h-shaped so you
walk in and you intend to go walk out
but there's another glass there and uh
you're meant to go that way and i went
into the glass the glass survived and my
head didn't um
but i'm okay i survived and uh just as
well you know when in norway do like the
norwegians and as we're going skiing
this weekend i came off the um airplane
and straight into duty-free to buy
alcohol
because alcohol is ridiculously
expensive in this country and luckily i
had a bottle of cider so i sat on the
train with a ball of cider on my head
and that helped the lump go down so
that's enough about me um let's get into
things
so we're going to talk about the modern
world the modern web is component driven
right if you're building applications
you're probably building in angular in
vue in svelt in react in etc etc now who
here is a front-end developer
nice quite a few you very cool who here
is a back-end developer
okay oh back end is winning here's a
full stack
i love that everyone just becomes full
stack it's great full stack is a new in
thing right a couple of years ago full
stack was like oh you don't know what
you're doing you just like you know are
not qualified in anything so you do
everything and now full stack is like
the in thing so that's very cool and if
you're here like in your devops you're
probably in the wrong talk um no money
missing you're very welcome as well if
you're project managers designers
whatever this talk is kind of like also
for anyone but mainly dealing with front
end and also like the back ends are
going to learn what the front end is
doing so that's also kind of cool
so the modern web is component driven
and we're all living in a perfect world
right
or are we
i mean covet happens so no
but when it comes to applications this
is basically how we're building
applications in the front end in
2021 uh what happens is covert came
along and that meant you know we need to
scale everything went online we needed
to build more and more and more more
applications uh we need we hired more
people we got more developers on board
and everything is just like
thrown in together and we have this one
big massive uh mess in the front end
so
let's go back in time a little bit let's
see you know where we all where it all
started and some of you
i'm looking some of you are as old as me
and some of you are
so young you won't even know this but
you know if we go back in time this is
how it started right we had monoliths
where we had php jquery html css
javascript throw it all into the one
application ship it and go is there
anyone still working like this with like
front and back end code all mixed
together
no thank god because i would have said
like you know you need a new job
so yeah this is how we used to work and
this is basically what we did right we
separated front and back it's pretty
simple right you know back end you go do
your stuff you want to do dotnetdo.net
you want to do php do hp php we don't
care and front end we want to do react
or vue or angular and the back end you
do your stuff we do our stuff more happy
right perfect situation
so
the back end got all clever on us didn't
they and they went oh we're going to
build microservices
and they started build splitting up
their back end monolith into these
wonderful micro services and um doing
all cool stuff
on the front end is basically here
excuse my um my art is not very good so
you know just push that in but you can
see how it's just changed right and the
front end is still that big massive
monolith that big massive stone of code
all the code is just in there
so um
so yeah micro services what are
microservices if there's anyone back in
here you could probably write these
slides better than me because i'm a
friend of developer so uh don't quote me
on all this but more or less this is
what microservices are
arranges the application as a collection
of lucy couple services
we've got split in terms of
responsibility or knowledge
we got incremental updates
independent deployments right
we've got smaller code bases because you
know they're micro
and we can scale a lot easier and that's
what we're doing in the back end or
that's what the back end teams are doing
most of them and
we're not doing that in the front end at
all
the front end is basically still a
monolith
it's still a mess
and you're probably thinking but hang on
a minute i'm building react applications
they're modern so you know i'm doing
everything right this is how react tells
you to do it how view tells you to do it
how angular tells you to do it so what
are you talking about debbie
well
your components are tightly coupled
and nested inside your application
and when you're building your
applications you're building that one up
and you're building your components
right inside that app
am i right
yeah
yeah the majority of you are basically
building apps i mean that's how we're
taught to do it right you create react
up and you start building all the
components in there unless you're
building kind of component libraries
which some of you might be but in
general this is how we're building
applications
so
that means that we end up with basically
a front-end monolith
we have one code base
and we've got no team ownership now you
might say okay yeah but you could do
like code owners from uh in github and
you could like separate some folders
that you know people can own that etc
but it's still you have still access to
kind of like the whole code base just on
pull request you might not have full
access
we've got one version and too many
components and it's very hard to scale
when you have a lot of components in one
codebase
and you've got one build right so every
time you know you want to update one
component you're basically building the
whole application because of that
component so it's kind of slow to
develop and move forward
and what happens when you need to scale
to multiple applications right we now
need to build i don't know a mobile
application or a secondary application
or some sort of um back-end type of
application for the login
facility or whatever so we now need to
scale to multiple apps what do we do
right we've built this amazing app and
it's really cool that all our components
are stuck inside the app
so we kind of say right we've got these
very three similar applications and some
of the components could be the same
like shopping cart components kind of
really big components
and you know what do you do anyone what
do you do
you duplicate the component don't you i
know you do i see you yeah i mean who
who here has duplicated components
yeah okay excellent so half of people
here are duplicating components i i've
done the same because it's literally
like you have a booking um card booking
engine component
and you need to use it now in this other
app what is the quickest and easiest
solution copy paste put it in there
because you know
basically like that code is never going
to change right it's always going to be
the same so you're never going to have
to maintain anything right but
then they come along and they change
things and things happen so now when you
duplicate the components you've got a
lot of code to maintain
and you can have inconsistency across
your application because obviously like
you know one team is working on one and
the other on another one is starting
going up in a different direction and
the others starting to look out of
control and if you've ever seen some
websites where the button component is
different on different pages the header
component the footer component um yeah
it's it's
it's real so inconsistency is a massive
problem when you're duplicating your
components
or you're reinventing the wheel right
because you take that component and then
you're like you know just kind of
building on top of it again and again
whereas you know you really just want to
have one component
and updating components over multiple
apps is very very time consuming and i
know one company which i will not say
the name
that we're working with that basically
uh took them six months to update the
logo component
across all their applications and
websites across every single country in
the world now you might say that's
ridiculous right but how do you update a
component on a large-scale uh
corporation right where you have to go
to certain project managers and all
these things by the time you go through
each of them and then you finally
updated the logo now you might say but
who updates their logo right well we do
on friday we you know if we put a pride
logo christmas we might put a christmas
logo um so logos to change things change
and basically we need to make it simple
to make one change and bang it's changed
across every application that's the
ideal world
so another solution is packaging
components right and you might say hey i
never duplicate my components i take
them put them in a package stick them up
in npm and happy days and yeah i've done
that as well in the past but it's also
you know when you do one component it's
kind of okay pretty good and then you do
another one and then you do another one
and then you do another one and you've
got all these package jsons to manage
and it can be an absolute
nightmare to manage and of course like
you know there are tools to help you
with that you've got learner for example
anyone used learner yeah so learners
it's okay you know it's not going to say
anything bad against learner it does its
job but it's not basically doing what
it's meant to do or it's what we wanted
to do right so learner isn't the perfect
solution but can work if if it makes you
happy and you're happy then stick with
it but you've got to manage all those
package jsons all those dependencies and
that can be a bit of a nightmare
um yeah updating updating dependencies i
don't know if you like doing that but um
no i don't like doing that it's also
very hard to discover components i don't
know if you've ever like gone to npm and
started to try and find a component um i
mean npm wasn't made for components
right so you don't have a nice ui of
seeing the components which means if
you're a company that has like 300
components on npm and then a neutral in
your dev comes in and you say
okay so error library is in npm go find
the components and start using those
components it's
it's pretty difficult to work with now i
know you're going to say yeah but we
build component libraries and we build
our own component library shop and and
then we have one package and then we
just download that one package and then
we use that in all our apps which is
another solution i built that as well um
but then you know you're up sending that
package up each time you make one change
you've got to like you know send that
package up again and again and again and
unless you've got like really good tree
shaking going on with webpack and stuff
you've got all these components in there
that you don't need so
it's not the ideal solution
so monorepos
is another solution right you know i've
got an idea let's draw the code in one
and then we can easily share our
components across all applications if we
want to scale to multiple applications
we can have three repos in there three
applications in there anyone here
working in mono rebels
okay quite a lot of you keep your hands
up if you like moana rebels
okay quite a lot of you that's
interesting hands up if anyone hates
monorebos
a few of you okay good so it's an
interesting battle here i'm gonna show
you um i'll show you the pros and cons
and i don't really have an opinion um
but i'll tell you what i kind of found
out from other people
so monorepo's have do have a lot of pros
i mean they improve velocity right it's
quickly it's very quick to develop
because you've got all access to all
components all code so it's like really
easy take that button component shopping
cart component show it in each
application happy days great
so we can share code reuse code very
very very easily
and the dev experience is actually
pretty good right because you know we
have access to everything so we don't
have to ask permission or or clone
another repo or do anything we get we
have everything right our feet so it's
pretty good experience
and refactoring at large scale is really
really easy because we have access to
all the code right so if we need to fix
the button component and the cart
component together we can do that we can
refactor everything very easily
and we can work across different teams
so we have one team that's you know
working on the shopping cart and another
team that's working on design components
they're all working in the one one
monorepo and they're all happy kind of
maybe
and we have standards right so you've
got only one eslint um to sort out one
printer file um so everyone's working
across the same standards
so monorepos are pretty good right so
all those who have your hands up you're
probably loving all this right
and the cons well you know
nothing is ever perfect
so the tooling basically isn't perfect
for mono wrappers learner wasn't really
built you know for mono wrappers it's
just built like to help you manage
packages and stuff so the tooling really
isn't built for it the same as um you
know git isn't built for it uh try get
clone on a massive massive project
you're waiting for ages to clone that
project and now you might say yeah but
you know get up have come up with that
solution and now we've got like you know
code spaces and that's like in the in
the cloud and that's much faster and
it's very true and that's why github um
built it because cloning projects take
so long so now they don't have to spend
so long when a new person comes on the
team but yeah the tooling isn't really
built
for monorepos
visibility and discoverability is hard
now you're going to say yeah but
it's easy to find components you said
right it is in the code but you're
working in vs code for example you do a
search for component and you find that
component but you can't really visualize
and see that component you're just
seeing the code and you kind of know it
exists but you don't really know
how it looks like what it does you're
really having to read the code so
discovering the components on how they
look and feel is kind of hard because
you're just like you know going into the
code
it's very easy to break someone else's
code right i don't know if you've ever
broken someone else's code but i have
so yeah you kind of don't know who's
using that component who's relying on it
so it's very easy to make some changes
and then like you know all hell breaks
loose and it's a disaster
onboarding developers is also quite hard
if you take a new developer and doesn't
have to be a junior developer could be a
very senior developer uh comes on into
your code base and basically you say
right you're going to work on the
shopping cart component but there's like
400 components in there or you know
could be even more than that there's a
lot of code in there and they've got to
like find their way around whereas
really if they just had one thing to to
look at one thing to to work out like
the shopping cart just that it would be
a lot easier
so yeah onboarding can be can be time
consuming and then you've got slow bills
because you're building you know so much
but then you might say yeah but we've
got like nx and that solves some of the
problems with caching and stuff and it
does nx has done a great job at that um
anyone using nx
yeah so that solves some of those
problems and it's pretty cool
but again it's still not the perfect
solution
team boundaries and ownership isn't
there like i said you could do code
owners
in github but
it's very difficult to say like don't
touch that code until it goes to the
pull request stage and that stage might
be too late so there's no kind of like
this is this team they own this code and
this is this team they own that code so
kind of sounds like i hate monorepos but
it's not that's not not really i kind of
said i don't know do you love or hate
monorepos i ask twitter because twitter
has all the answers right
so yeah twitter came back to me and they
kind of said some interesting things
like garrett says i only have experience
in one but we managed to end up in a
situation where every consuming repo has
to import every package in the monorepo
so we have the crappy tooling and bloat
of a monorepo and none of the claimed
benefits
oliver said he's a huge fan he loves
them but the tooling hasn't helped
solutions like lerner were hamstrung by
the npm client's limitations
and brandon who actually works at nx
said he loves the shared code between
ops and libraries the visibility the
collaboration the consistency the
ability to standardize single package
versions that's what we want but he
hates the insufficient tooling which
makes the experience bad
it can lead to bloated ci times and lots
of ad hoc scripts and if you look at all
these the three things that they have in
common not my words these guys words the
tooling hasn't helped crappy tooling
insufficient tooling
so that's the aim of what we need to fix
today we need to fix the tooling if the
tooling is better we can do a better job
right
now this is if we're kind of like
scaling across multiple applications
you might be saying yeah but i'm only
building one application so you know i'm
just building in one kind of
one way so i don't really need that
maybe i don't need to share components
across you know different repos okay
cool fine
if you're scaling one app then you
probably have this one large app again
like i said before everyone's working on
that massive code base
it's hard to discover your components
it's hard to give teams ownerships
it's still like one main branch that
you're working on okay you're gonna
branch off for your features and stuff
but you know it's still one main branch
that you're gonna deploy
you have no internal versioning for any
of your components you only have a
version at this at the up level
and you have like one long build time
because you're building the up all the
time
to add in every time you're making one
small change to your component
and then you're managing multiple
multiple deployments so basically you
still have the same problem as the
monorepos right the same kind of
problems and that's what we're trying to
solve here today
so
let's break down the front end monolith
once and for all that's what we're going
to do that's what i'm going to show you
how to do
so are you ready first of all what we
need to do is let teams own features
this is the ideal world right if you
could build and work in the ideal world
this is what we want to do we want teams
to own features so they come in and say
this is what i work on i'm the you know
shopping cart team for example and
that's all i care about is making sure
that shopping cart component and
everything that it needs works and is
okay and someone else is building
whatever they can do whatever and work
and whatever and i don't want to know
about it because it's not you know my
responsibility
so we break this down um we could have
different teams like a support team for
example
so we get the support team and they have
like you know a support uh request
component that they own and they work on
that could be a form for example
then they might have an online chat
widget you know to chat with the people
for support and they own that component
as well
and then they might have the support
tickets right that's another component
they own that could be a whole page
that's a big component remember
components pages are also components
and a support ticket dashboard that page
is also theirs now that's the support
team whoever how many developers are on
that support team that's their
components and that's what they're
responsible for and that's what they're
going to build
and you might have a product team
and the product team could have a
shopping cart component
the get product component the hook for
example a react hook is is also a
component they might have the product
card
component that shows all the products
and the product page that shows all
those product cards so that's what
they're responsible for
and then you've got the design team
right the design team
could have the button component you know
famous button that's used everywhere
across every single application um the
card component which might just be a you
know a shape with a border so that all
cards kind of look the same and feel the
same it doesn't have to have anything
inside it
and then you might have the logo
component right this is used across your
application maybe in the support tickets
in the header and the footer etc etc
and it could be a tooltip component you
know that's used across your application
so the design team works on those
components
and then basically you have the solution
where you have
these three teams and they're doing
their job independently building their
components independently support team
takes their components and puts them up
to the support scope
the product team takes their components
and they put them up to the product
scope
and the design team they make their
components and they send them up to the
design scope
now you're going to say what's a scope
right and you know some people do know
what a scope is scope of ice cream it
can be many things scope can mean a lot
of things a scope is basically um a
next-gen micro service allowing teams to
own and expose apis that include both
front-end apis back-end apis and even
node modules that's my definition um
i'll show you though
so this is um how i'm building with
scopes right and we have um basically
just a load of scopes are a load of like
you could say like domain driven
development kind of things like you're
thinking of your domain um that's your
scope so we could have like a base ui as
a scope uh this is kind of like the
projects i built some of them are
terrible some of them are amazing um so
look at the amazing ones only but yeah
you can have the base ui the design um
i've got like e-commerce in there the
shoe store i built a perfume store
electronics store they're all different
scopes
so just to give you an idea yeah that's
the base ui one and that's what i'm
going to show you how we built the demo
project that i built i used the base ui
and the e-commerce and the shoe store
they're three separate teams um that
built these uh now basically you're
probably seeing my picture on all of
those that's because i have nobody on my
team i know it's very sad but normally
you would have like different teams
owning that so you've got to just
imagine that actually that's built with
different teams but i actually had to
build everything um but we are hiring
you know case you want to join me um so
yeah every scope can have its own
wrapper right so
base ui has its own wrapper now base ui
is not an application based ui is just
like design components or base
components that i'm reusing across every
application e-commerce is a repo with
just e-commerce components no
application just components that are
then being built and used to create the
e-commerce applications i have four
applications because just i felt like
building four different shops and then
i've got like those four applications
built as separate wrappers
and you can kind of
visualize it like this
so you can kind of see you know which um
which scope depends on who what their
dependencies are how they're connected
and how they're you know using things so
you could also like maybe see that you
know something isn't using the
e-commerce components and then you'd be
like whoa hang on a second you built
this application you didn't build my
build it with the e-commerce components
that's a problem because now we're
duplicating components so you can kind
of like see how they're all connected
together
so when it comes to teams basically how
we want teams to work is that teams you
want teams to own features right you
want to own your work don't you want to
go to work and say i do this this is
mine i want to ship it deploy it and
then go home on a friday and not worry
about anyone else i want to work
independent from the other people
they're doing that great job like we
love the other team but you know let
them do their job i want to do my job my
team you know i have my deadlines and
get my job done and you want to have
separate build pipelines right i don't
want to have to like a build on a friday
everyone like build on a friday and ship
it on a friday i used to do that that
was terrible decision who makes
decisions like that
so yeah build pipelines you want them to
have separate so that you can build that
shopping cart and just build that one
and someone else is building those base
components which could be like i don't
know the button components of the logo
component and they can deploy them
separately and not have to wait for one
team to finish
and you want to be able to test them
independently as well which is also very
important i mean i hope you're all
writing tests are we all writing tests
not really kind of maybe yeah we should
all be writing tests i'm not writing
tests i'm writing sometimes i'm trying
but it is hard we should write more
tests um and yeah we want to ship the
components individually so that
components they're shipped they're done
and you know then we just want to like
work
um on our own have autonomy and like i
said on a friday go home and have beers
and if the other team didn't do their
job then yeah their problem not my
problem cool
so that's what we want is anyone
actually working like this at the moment
one person excellent two people cool i
want to speak to you later see what
you're doing so two people out of a
whole room are doing oh three didn't see
you okay four we got four four people
are working like this excellent the rest
of you are not shame on you no don't
worry i'm going to help you sort your
lives out
so um apps are composed from components
right we all know that nothing our
applications we're just composing them
from components
so this is um a dependency graph from
the ecommerce store i created showing
all the components that are used to
build up that application
shows you how they're all connected
together i know it's a bit small but
just to give you the idea of the tree
and it kind of goes quite a long way
away because there's quite a lot of
components used to build up that
e-commerce application
now my e-commerce store is beautiful i
know this is what it looks like and um
pretty much everything is oh and we lost
connection damn
i lost connection here did you lose
collection
okay it's back here is it back there
excellent okay sometimes the mac did
that i did a last conference just shut
off for like 10 seconds okay so we're
back so yeah we have basically the um
e-commerce application here and the logo
is coming from the base ui scope or base
ui repo depending on how you want to
think about it
and then we have the e-commerce
components they're coming from the
e-commerce scope or e-commerce repo
depending on how you want to think about
it and then we have the shoe store which
also has its own components because you
might want to hear a component that's
specific to the shoe store that you know
the e-commerce
team you don't want them to own it
because you want to basically own it
yourself and kind of like change it
modify it and build it you know
differently to how the other e-commerce
stores are being built etc so it's a
matter of deciding how you want to kind
of who who should own your components
right and that's when you're building
them that's how you should uh think
about it
so to do component driven it basically
means it's a reuse based approach to
defining implementing and composing
loosely
loosely being the word loosely coupled
independent components into systems
right so we want to try and loosely
couple now it's
you should say like you know just like
decouple them completely right but
sometimes you will have some coupling
two components and that's okay but you
don't want to have heavily coupled
components which i know how i have in my
app um so that's not good in my previous
apps now i do things right because i
learned the right way
but yeah when you're building like your
components so this is my beautiful
shoes card component where i you know
sell shoes on my ecommerce site
and this is basically built up from a
card component right this is kind of you
know you're probably all going debbie we
know all this we do the same i know just
bear with me so we've got the card and
then we break it down we've got a
heading component and now you might not
do that you might be just throwing a h2
in there but actually if you if you make
the h2a component that's now a heading
component it means if you were to modify
anything across your application that
one small component will be modified and
it's just a lot easier
and then you've got like a text
component so this would be like you know
your general text or paragraph or
whatever an image component now you
might say well we don't need an image
component because we just use the image
tag and you're just putting source in
there and an alt in there and maybe lazy
loading right
and i would kind of agree with you and
then i would say yeah but then you know
i i used to work at nooks i don't know
if you know nooks from the view
frameworks
but nook's just released their next
image
module and basically what that does is
it kind of um gives you better
performance of your images so now in my
personal website which i have like i
don't know about 150
image tags
um that was fun
to wake you all up i like that um i have
about 150 image tags and now i've got to
refactor my whole application to use the
next image because the next image tag is
a lot more performant it's going to
allow me to have better performance and
you know i can you know
change widths and heights depending on
mobile versions etc and i know there's
one for next um for gatsby as well right
so there are reasons why if you had done
this out as just an image component now
you just make one change and you got
that change across um your whole
application you might have to modify the
api a little bit but you know
um and then you've got the button
component again um the button component
is one of the most used components
across any application
so that's in there and then you've got
the currency component again you might
say yeah but why would you need a
currency component
but you might want to say yeah but i
just want them to have dollars and i
don't know british pounds for example we
might be going into the uk market and
then all of a sudden we go to euromarket
you want to
be allow them to use the euro et cetera
and yeah basically then you want to be
able to see the components so
here we've got like um the components
where we're able to kind of see
everything everything running where
every component is coming from and as
you can kind of scroll down you can see
and you can actually click and go direct
to that component and what that allows
you to do is it allows project managers
to actually see that yes you're using
the components from the correct scopes
from the correct repos allows designers
to see that they're coming there it'll
you can kind of get inconsistencies see
them beforehand and say actually that
component um should not come from there
and you can also see so maybe you want
to look at some of the um a card
component and say whoa i want to use
that component where is it how can i
find it and you could like see and you
know visualize it and then click
directly onto that component
so yeah the shopping uh the shopping
cart the product card component looks
pretty much like this pretty simple one
and it just has these kind of
dependencies so i can see exactly how
that's made up from the dependency graph
what versions of each of those
components that it's using so i think my
buttons on version two i'll show you
that later because i made a much better
button the first button was terrible um
so yeah you can see that this this uh
ecommerce site is using um the shopping
cart or the button from version two but
another one is actually using the button
from version one etc and you can kind of
see what's going on
and yeah i made lovely graphics as well
to show you so that's coming from the
base scope
this one is the shoe store scope that's
um i built the product card for the shoe
store in the actual shoe store because i
wanted that shoe store team um
to basically own that product card and
kind of like take it a little bit
further into a direction that's
different but
if you go into the actual component
details they're actually still using the
entity component from the e-commerce
so they're taking that entity component
but they're extending it and adding
things like shoe size because the
perfume store did not need shoe sizes so
it's taking all those types all those
entities and then just extending on top
of it
which means if i modify something in the
e-commerce i'm going to get those
benefits in the actual shoe store but
still have my shoe size and colors and
whatever else the shoes have that the
perfume store doesn't need
um so yeah we're still reusing things
from other components but um we have our
own ownership of that component
and then the currency component is
coming from the e-commerce i don't think
the shoe store team needs to own the
currency because you know it's fine
e-commerce can own that and they can you
know decide if we're going to go into
different markets etc
so
how do we actually build component
driven right that's the question right
anyone have an answer to this everyone
think does anyone think they are
building component driven anyone
building component driven okay we got
one person two one no one one person
okay cool i'm gonna have a chat with you
later we'll have lots to talk about this
is cool so um i used to think i was
building component driven i was like i'm
building components until i change jobs
and then my ceo had a chat with me he's
like debbie no that is not how you do
things i'm like really but i've been
doing that forever
seriously
yeah but basically what you need to do
is think about every component as a
product for anyone to use now i
definitely did not build my pro my
components thinking like that i was
building them simply for me i was
actually just building i would build a
whole product card component and then
like take a button out and make it a
component and take something out and
make it a component anytime i felt it
was being needed to be reused but i
never started thinking of small pieces
as individual components
and i never considered anyone else is
going to use my components because why
would they want to use my components
right but you know when you work for big
teams big enterprises a lot of people
are using your components
so your component basically should have
a great developer experience i mean
that's what you want you want developers
to be happy to love what you're doing so
this is really important um you want to
you want them to be able to use them in
different contexts like throw different
themes on top so they can be styles
different can look different
they should be easy to use right your
components it should be very easy for
someone to take your component and use
your component
the api should be really well explained
so you can see what's available to you
and then be able to just you know use it
um and
and see what you can what you can do
with that component and it should be
loosely coupled right so like you know
data etc um try and use you know not
couple to stores and things like that
and once you do that then you're going
to have developers who are going to
write better software right if
developers write better software they're
just happier which is kind of cool we
want we want developers to be happier
but they are going to write more
maintainable software right it's going
to be much easier to maintain
it's going to be much easier to test i
know you all love testing
but it is going to be much easier to
test and the dev experience is going to
be great
and then organizations what are they
going to get of course organizations are
going to get better software because the
developers are writing better software
they're also going to be happy
developers and they're going to save a
lot of time right because you're not
like rebuilding multiple components etc
so organizations are going to save time
and they're going to save money and
that's what they care about right so
organizations your bosses are going to
be happy if you walk in there and say
i'm going to build component driven
and you're going to have happier devs
and once we all have happier devs life
is just so much better right
so that's what we're trying to do
now component driven we take your
components and we basically want to make
them themeable you want your components
to be able to use in different
applications and let you know different
teams be able to like you know throw a
different theme on there and have it
like look a little bit different or
whatever
you want them to be composable so you
can compose components on top of other
components
you want them to be encapsulated you
want them to be independent from any
other and you want them to be reusable
you want your components to be able to
be reused across multiple and many
applications
so to give you an example um from
something i created themeable i mean we
all know what themeable is right you
know design components with themes so
they can be used differently in other
apps right basically straightforward and
this is just my example here of my two
product cards from the um the shoe store
and then from the perfume store same
component exactly the same minor change
and um you know we've got two very
different components i know there's a
line under the underneath the image and
the pink thing don't look at that
i'll fix it tomorrow um then we've got
composable right so you want
your apps to basically compose you want
to be able to compose smaller components
together to build more complex
components right we kind of already
talked a little bit about it and this is
uh basically the product card that we
saw earlier and that's those um smaller
components uh completely independent
components that are used to build up
that component that one product card
component so when i build my application
i just want to take the product card
component in and the product card
component thinks and deals with you know
all those other components they just
like are automatically part of it so i
don't have to in you know include all
these little ones i'm just including
that one one complex composed component
so encapsulated um exposes interfaces
which allow the caller to use its
functionality and we want to hide
details of internal variables in state
so basically like we want to be able to
you know use props right if you're using
kind of building front end um you want
to be able to have them use like
for title proper text proper source for
alt and build out your component the api
of the component thinking of
how they can change things what they can
change maybe the currency maybe you want
them to change any and have any currency
or maybe you want to only have um
dollars and euros because maybe you know
brexit and you know we don't want to
have to deal with pounds anymore because
they're like doing their own thing so
yeah you can basically choose how do you
want to build that api and you have to
think about that when you're actually
building the component
and then you want the component to be
independent
so if components are independent um they
basically have their own version and
their own revision history which means
you should be able to go back in time at
any moment and you know use an older
version if you needed to um and it
should have its own revision history so
you can like go back in time and see you
know how it kind of changed what's
happening to that component etc
and they should have their own build
pipeline so that basically you can build
that component and then just you know
build it independently from anything
else
and then you want to have minimal
dependencies on other components like
obviously you want to consume components
but you don't don't want to be dependent
on other kind of um bigger components
like you know if this breaks this is
going to break etc
and yeah this looks something like this
each component has its own version and
you can see like here the card is on
version
0.11 and the image is on the same
version and the buttons on version 2.03
etc
and then you want the components to be
reusable so basically you want to be
able to reuse them in different
scenarios in the same or in different
applications depending on what you're
building who you're working for and what
you're doing so again just a very simple
example the button component is used in
the product card and it's used in that
hero component um again obviously be
used much more across the application in
many different places but just
kind of see what's going on now when
you're building your component i'm just
going to take a button component which
is just a very it can be very simple
component can also be a very complex
component but this is how you want to
build your components right
now you want to document components so
that when someone comes along they can
actually see what your component can do
if you're documenting it you also want
to add your designs in there as well so
your designs can come directly from
figma so if your designer changed
anything you can then have your
compositions right under the designs so
you can see exactly what's going on and
if they're the same and so can the
design or the project manager you wanna
have all your api props in there so you
can see what is available to you and
what you can use
and you wanna give people like you know
a little kind of a live playground so
you can play around with it and see it
in real time and change it and you know
what would happen if i removed something
what would it look like if i added this
in um the link is a component there what
if i remove that and add it in as a
secondary button etc how would it look
and how would it behave so if you
provide someone with this kind of
information they can really trust your
component then they can open and see
every single way that that component can
be composed so they can kind of see like
okay this this component gives me
everything i want we've got like tests
that are like documentation features
because they really kind of test
everything that that button does
and you can see does it depend on
anything and you can also see the code
which is really important so i can
actually see that it's using sas and i
can see who built it what the code is
like
and actually see you know do i really
trust this component this developer do
they write good code
and then i want to see the the version
history
which means i can then go back in time
to see every single version of that
component and um you know i'll show you
a component from when i started you know
don't judge me i was only a learner then
and i built uh you can see my
documentation from the first time i
built this component it's very different
right it's not very good i had no
designs in there uh i learned the hard
way my boss said debbie come on you need
you could do better than this um and
yeah so it was the designs were terrible
but you know maybe you want to still use
those designs because maybe you might
have um you can see it's much nicer now
i did get a designer to come along and
help though but yeah you might have um
two applications that are on different
different designs for different reasons
i know a company in australia that well
i'll tell you that in a second here you
can see how you can install the
component using using bit using npm or
using yarn so you can easily use it in
any of your projects
but yeah i know a company that was
basically updating their applications um
slowly so they couldn't update all the
components at once because then one
application you know wasn't ready to use
that component etc so being able to have
version one version two meant they could
just like you know keep one on tailwind
and the other on on sas etc and then
once they were ready and it finished the
oh you know every team was ready they
could just then you know change and use
the other version so that's what
basically what you want to do
so
that means then basically what we're
doing is we're decoupling all our
everything right we're getting all our
components here this is how the
e-commerce store is made up this
shoe store application these are all the
components that are now independent
components and they're used to build up
this application
and this is what it looks like on on
github right we have the base ui
um
repo there we have the e-commerce repo
the the stores repo and there's you know
more in there and we could have more
repos in there now
for all of you who love monorepos you're
saying yeah but i love working in modern
repos right and that's cool because you
can still work in a mono rapper right
and that's totally up to you that's how
you want to work i actually started
building this whole thing in a monorepo
um because it was easier yeah and i had
i didn't have to work in different repos
and it made sense but then as it scaled
it was like okay this is getting hard to
manage i'm taking on other people now
into the team so i want to start
separating it separating it out and you
can do that you can change you can start
in a monorepo uh basically everything is
independent so all the components are
independent what's important is the
scope when you're building it's kind of
like the domain driven development
thinking right when you build thinking
about where your component should live
on a scope the repo does not matter
because you can change that and move it
to another repo without any problems but
the scope is important that's going to
be the package name that you use to
install that component later that cannot
change or you'll break everything or you
can i mean you can get around it you can
remove it and re-add it and do things
like this but you want to kind of think
about that first
so yeah you can still work in your
monorepos um or you can work in
multi-repos um by basically this is my
next step what i did i took the base ui
components out i gave them their own
repo i gave the e-commerce their own
repo and then i put all my applications
into one monorepo and that worked as
well and then the kind of applications
got bigger and bigger and stuff so then
i basically had decoupled code bases and
now everything is in its own repo now
which one is correct
there's absolutely no correct and no
incorrect one anything that you do when
it comes to like how you want to work
it's up to you and what works best for
you or for your teams so if you want to
work in monorepos polyreports or
decoupled code bases
it depends on what you want to do but
you can start off i would start off as a
monorepo and then kind of like think and
kind of separate it out as you need it
so basically yeah this is um
these are the scopes um what it looks
like and you can kind of see how you
scroll down through each scope you can
see the components that are available to
you
this is a movies one as well
that we created and you can basically
just like see at all times what
components are available how they look
like
and you can search and filter for them
etc so components are very easily
visible which is what you want you want
your developers to find the components
so they can then go and open those
components check out the code check out
the tests check out what it looks like
and then decide you know yes that's the
component that i want to use we also
have like configs in there like eslint
as a component printer as a component so
that if you're working across
multi-repos or decouple code bases you
can share the eslint config as a
component you just open your eslint in
that like application
or in the development environment of
your components in that workspace and
then you just add that one
component.eslint and then if you modify
that eslint you just modify it once and
everyone's got the same eslint you know
like no console and then like you know
you can just like break everyone's app
at the same time which is cool you're
gonna not put no console logs in my apps
so yeah you can have your prettiers and
your con and your eslint as a component
everything can be component right that's
that's what we want to i want you to
walk away here and like if you never you
know do what i'm doing whatever just
always think everything can be a
component and if you think like that you
can really like break anything down
so
yeah compose components to create
applications that's what we want to do
we want to build
independent components and then we want
to just compose
and create applications and if you do
that like you can actually just build so
much faster and i've tested out i've
like built quite a lot of stuff now and
it really does make a difference so this
um
this one here is my shoe store that
you'll be able to see i'll share the
demo with you so you can see it and
these are the composition of the shoe
store and you can highlight over every
single component there to see exactly
where it's coming from uh what scope
it's coming from um what repo is coming
from and basically just see how it's all
made up which means anyone else can come
along here and actually just like you
know see how that's how it's built um so
you can you know learn from it or say
wow you're using that component from
that that place etc etc
so yeah you want to be able to see um at
each time how they're built up
and how it's created
and then you want to just reuse those
components in any app so i've got you
know this beautiful shoe store and then
i made a electronic store selling
headphones um and obviously that button
is a lot uglier because i haven't
updated it that's using an older version
of the button i think it's on version
one point something uh it's in between
the the start and the the finished one
um and then like i've got a beautiful
perfume store um don't try and buy
anything because the demo doesn't like
allow you to buy anything so don't get
too excited um if you want to give me
money you can give me money but um but
it doesn't work it will work in a couple
of weeks i'm working on it and then yeah
you could build like just a sports store
so you can build different stores very
quickly now i'm one person working on
this and i was able to build multiple
stores super quick um i know a company
in australia that are building multiple
applications and they were just like
just there's a whole like um video of
him explaining how they did what they
did with a very small team and just like
they were like wow how quickly they were
able to build things the problem is how
you start it right if you start it right
and think about components at the start
you can do anything but obviously if you
just build one application and just
troll your components in the app then
you've got all that problem of like now
how do i scale etc
so yes start with decoupling start
thinking about how you want to build
your components how you want things um
to be and think about how teams you know
which teams should own which components
what scopes they should be in think
about everything think about the apis
and then decide right now that can be in
its own repo etc and that can just you
know make your life easier
um and everything in these in these repo
so the sports store for example is using
the components from each of these repos
and they're i'm using bit to install
them you could use npm to install them
you could use yarn to install them you
could actually go to these this repo and
you can create your own shoe store
picking all my components and just yarn
add or npm install and just use all
those components
so that's kind of cool
um component driven basically means that
the components are truly isolated um
they're scoped to a particular team so
everyone has their own components to
work on their own job to do
they're independently versioned as i
showed you
they're independently released so you're
releasing components when they're
finished when they're ready and they're
no longer coupled to an app unless you
particularly want them to be and that's
you know maybe one that's also cool but
they shouldn't be coupled to an app you
can still build them in the app so you
could still open an xjs application for
example and then you know put the
components in there and reuse them in
another application and they might like
live in that you know next yes
application but they're still not couple
checkers are independent but it might
make sense to put them in a repo
separate but again up to you how you
want to build
and then they can be consumed in the app
in any app and in many apps
um and something i didn't mention but
i'll mention here so when we're talking
about you know those repos and how teams
are working so you can also take uh so
like it's kind of like a difference
between a package and a component right
um so when we talk about independent
components we're talking about the
component and the source code is shipped
with the component so if we're working
on a team for example me and david are
working on a team together and he goes
on holiday and he broke something in his
code and he went on holiday because
that's what he does
and uh and now we've got this you know
problem and
we're kind of like i work on a different
team but i could fix his component i'm
in a different code base i'm a different
workspace now what do i do i could get i
could clone the repo and then like
change that component but i hate cloning
repos i'm still just in my code base i
want to stay in my code base so i can
just import the component in i will get
all the source files right it won't go
into npm into node modules it will go
into actually my my workspace into vs
code i have access to all that code and
then i can make that change i can fix
that bug that david broke and then i can
basically tag a new version export it
back into the scope and then i can say i
do not want david's component in my code
base so i just eject it and bang he come
back from holiday and then he gets he
doesn't get whatever and it's like oh
you've got a new version and he just
like you know imports and he's got that
new changes that i made
so that's the kind of cool thing and the
main difference between when you're
working with packages and when you're
components right you want to be able to
modify things
so yes we want to say goodbye to the
monoliths that's what we're here to do
today um the back end is going to work
with microservices obviously if they
need it maybe it's a small back and they
don't but like you know
if it's a massive project they probably
need microservices on the front end
whether you need it or not you should
build with independent components
because then if you do have to scale if
things you know change in the future you
are already set up to do it i built my
website not like this i built my website
um which is an amazing by the way um but
if i now decide to build a streaming uh
website to you know share all my youtube
stuff and my streaming i have to either
you know start from beginning or
duplicate my components or whatever
because they're all built in the app so
i've seen that i can't scale my own app
and that's just me personally so imagine
a massive like company and um yeah a big
team of people
so yes basically what we want to do is
break down that monolith and uh thank
you very much for listening i hope you
enjoyed it and if you want to see
everything this is the demo project you
can scan it you can check it out there
is a readme component i created which
shows the github repos you can click
easily to that so you can see i'm not
making all this up uh you can clone it
you can play with it it's a completely
open source uh bit is open source and
everything all my components they're not
amazing but they're also open source and
you're free to use them i might break
them so be careful um and yeah bit is
completely open source unless you want
to use like cloud kind of stuff um
enterprising stuff and the sharing and
team all that kind of team stuff but if
not everything's free you can use the
big cloud for free as well so if you
wanted to put your components onto the
cloud you can do that for free as well
if you want private ones i think that's
paid um but you can also just put them
in your own docker container and
self-host them yourself you can also
just also put them to npm if you want
and still use so i've written a couple
of articles about that as well so yeah
it's open source and do check it out and
i hope you build better software and
thank you very much
we have like eight minutes for questions
if anyone does have any questions you
can ask away i will try and answer them
and if not you can all go drink coffee
yes go ahead how do you actually
implement
how do you implement it so how does it
like
how do you use it yeah so um basically
if you're working in the same workspace
so imagine the e-commerce
product card component um contains the
currency component right they're in the
same workspace so if i modify the
currency component then when i tag that
version of the currency component i add
the you know us dollar in there or
whatever then the product card will auto
update because it knows because of the
dependency graph knows it it kind of
needs that new version so the product
card will get a new update now if i'm
working in separate code bases
so i've got the base ui say the button
component and then the product card i
update the button how the product card
needs the new update of the button now
this is where you do have to kind of
manually do it just like you would
manually do an npm package update um
which is not ideal but there we are
working on something called ripple ci
which we're using internally at the
moment it's not um it's not available
yet but it will be and what this does is
it kind of simulates um across all your
dependency graph where that component is
being used and simulates a kind of um
what it would look like so i don't know
if you use netlify deploy previews for
example i kind of like you know going by
that so you can see what it would look
like if it was deployed and then you can
say you know yes and then it will like
accept that pull request and you know
take that um new version so that's the
kind of future thing that we're working
on which is very cool and we're building
with it internally um but at the moment
we've got to like you know um come on
you do like a bit import new import and
and then basically update to version two
which gives you control as well because
maybe you don't want to update the
version too because you know you saw my
my buttons are different in different
applications so you do want that control
as well but yeah sometimes some of them
has to be manually done which is the way
it is but it's getting better
good question anyone else any questions
yes
what do i think of module federation um
so we're working with zachary jackson um
who built module federation um and we're
putting module federation um into into
bits to be able to like build your
components with module federation what
do i personally think of it um it
depends on what you're doing and if you
need it again you're going into runtime
versus build time um we also built
something that allows you to actually
turn an angular component into a web
component so that we can use it in a
react application i don't think you
should do that um do you want to do that
do you need to do that maybe there are
teams out there that are you know taking
angularjs and they're literally like
migrating across to react and therefore
there are times when you know that
component is so complex that it's
necessary so it's all kind of opening up
a whole kind of worms when it comes into
like module federation and a runtime
build time and et cetera it depends on
what you need depends on what you want
to do it's like when you talk about
microfrondens right people are all
saying we need microfront ends and we we
get so many people coming to us we need
microfrondens and it's like what problem
are you trying to solve like we want
teams to own features well then you
don't need microfrontends as you call
micro front ends with runtime in bold
time etc you just need to build
independent components
so yeah but we are implementing module
federation working with zachary on that
um so
it's going to be interesting how it
works but we have everything's in
webpack five because zach already put
web pack five in all our system and
that's all cool so it's all set up and
it's just a matter of a couple of weeks
before he finishes that i know he has it
working really well in in lola mall
lollamon i bought leggings in there in
canada last week and is in the shop he
works in and he has modular federation
doing great stuff in that so he's
working on that um it will be
interesting to see how it goes in the
future and what people do with it and
i'm interested to see what mess people
make with their code base i can see i
can see a lot of messes happening
yeah but good question anyone else any
questions
batman
no
okay so my twitter handler is dev's
underscore brian my dms are always open
so feel free to send me a message if you
want to talk more about components um
about taekwondo about hitting your head
off revolving doors or anything else uh
come and see me i'm gonna have ice cream
that's what i'm gonna do i don't know
what usually gonna do is one more talk
left i hope you really enjoy it um the
party tonight's gonna be amazing if
you've never seen the line breakers like
do not miss it it's gonna be incredible
and enjoy the rest of conference
everyone and come and see if you need
anything thank you very much
[Applause]
you